one spring afternoon in 2015 I decided  to visit the world in a day  New York opens itself up to those  willing to explore it so the view from  elsewhere can be glimpsed and enjoyed by  wandering the city streets  I want to witness all across the city  how people take their home country with  them to New York and adapt easily or  uneasily to this challenging metropolis  I want to see how people long for home I  want to observe how they declare this is  my home for as long as I can remember  I've been a walker one who makes sense  of the world by strolling through it  many immigrants from countries where the  Walker has not been displaced by the  automobile lay claim to the city by  grasping it underfoot they warm up to it  at walking pace so I walked to connect  with the city but also to connect with  other immigrants who pursue home step by  step encounter by encounter ambition by  ambition  the way I do  [Music]  you  [Music]